In monadic image processing we take an input
image and we apply a function to every single
pixel in that image.
The result of the function applied to a particular
pixel in the input image is assigned to the
corresponding pixel in the output image, and
we use the same function for every pixel within
the image.
Let’s have a look at this low-resolution
example to get an idea of how it works in practice.
So we have a function, which we apply to the
first pixel input image, and the result is
assigned to the first pixel in the output
image. And then we do the same thing for the
second pixel and the third pixel and so on,
until we have processed every single pixel
within the image.
Now the demonstration here is sequential;
we have applied it to one pixel after another.
If the computer has significant parallel processing
power then it is possible to apply the function
to all of the pixels in parallel.
So what is this function f(x) that we used
in the previous example? Well there are lots
of really useful functions that we could use.
The first is, perhaps, we could take the square
root of the input pixel.
Another thing we could do is change the type
of the input pixel. Perhaps we could convert
unsigned integer pixels into double pixels
or vice versa.
Maybe we could change the brightness or the
contrast of the image by operating on each
pixel individually.
We could perform a function called histogram
normalisation, and we will talk about that
in a following section.
We could perform an operation called thresholding,
which we will also talk about in upcoming
section.
And we could perform an arty kind of transformation
called posterization, and again we will talk
about that very shortly.